In the previous video we talked about it
how important is glucose as a simple sugar.
We also talked about its molecular structure.
In this video we'll look at how the Gucci
can be a building block
more complex sugars and more complex carbohydrates.
Here I am
two molecules of glucose, we can number their carbon atoms.
It's number one, two, three, four, five, six.
One two three four five six.
The molecules are in their cyclic form.
Now we will see
what will happen if this oxygen atom here -
I will paint him in the manga,
if this atom uses one of its free electronic pairs,
to participate
in the so-called organic chemistry
nucleophilic reaction with the first carbon atom
of the glucose molecule on the left.
This can happen,
because the first carbon atom here
is connected to two oxygen atoms.
Oxygen is highly electronegative.
Oxygen atoms attract electrons to themselves when they engage in a covalent bond.
That's why this carbon atom will have
partial positive charge.
This oxygen atom is highly electronegative.
It will attract electrons from this hydrogen atom
and carbon atom number four
in the glucose molecule on the right.
This will give him a partial negative charge.
Therefore, the reaction is nucleophilic.
Will be attracted by
the nucleus (nucleus = nucleus) of the carbon atom from the partially positive charge
right here. When this happens,
the oxygen atom will use its free electron pair to form a bond.
You will share it with the atom,
and the carbon atom will be released from another bond.
He will be released
of the two electrons in this connection.
Now you can decide that they simply
are returned to oxygen to give a hydroxide anion?
Maybe it will be used first,
to form a hydroxide ion
or maybe that link right away
is bound to hydrogen ion from the solution
by another hydroxone ion in the solution.
Can be used for connection
with this hydrogen ion,
which is simply a proton.
We remove an electron from the hydrogen atom
and a proton is obtained.
What will happen then?
These two molecules will be linked.
They'll connect like that.
It is important to follow the molecules here.
This oxygen atom is this oxygen atom.
Here is this.
That relationship between carbon atom number four
to the right of this oxygen atom
is this link here.
And here we have an electronic couple,
to form the bond with carbon atom number one,
I will color it in the guy.
This connection here is here.
This oxygen atom is now that oxygen atom here.
And this e-pair has now formed a relationship
with this hydrogen atom,
I will color it in blue,
this is the link here.
On my drawing
this oxygen atom is
linked to carbon atom number one here and
number four here.
We've already done it here.
Carbon atom number one in the left molecule
and number four on the right.
But we also connected it
with a hydrogen atom.
As I drew it here,
is still connected to hydrogen.
There will be a common positive charge.
It was neutral here.
It was neutral here, but
now shares his electrons.
Now he shares these two electrons
in a covalent bond. You can imagine that
gives its electrons to this carbon atom
and now has a positive charge.
But to return to neutrality,
water molecule
can take that ion, maybe this one.
It can be connected to this hydrogen.
These electrons, both -
It will only snap the hydrogen nucleus of the proton
and these two electrons will return
with this oxygen, which will become neutral.
So we will get the following,
I will delete this.
This hydrogen atom is now connected
with this oxygen and we have a hydroxone ion.
This is logical.
We had a hydroxone ion.
We had a hydrogen proton here, and we still have it.
It is now connected with water,
so we took a proton and returned a proton,
so we have no added charge
or discharged from the system.
The important thing is that
when these two things came together,
we lost the molecule of water. Generally
this system lost the molecule of water.
Get a charge to do it to create a molecule of water.
But the thing that really disappeared from
these two molecules are
this is here.
This H is this, this oxygen is this one.
And this hydrogen atom is this one.
Type of reaction in which
we synthesize a more complex molecule,
a longer chain of glucose molecules,
is called dehydration.
What we did here
Why do we call it that?
Because we have separated the molecule of water.
If you imagine you lose water,
you imagine dehydration.
At the same time, we associate two things,
to synthesize a larger molecule.
Sometimes this is called condensation.
Condensation.
When they connect, these two molecules
form a disaccharide.
Each in itself was a monosaccharide,
the one on the right is monosaccharide.
What does monosaccharide mean?
Mono means single or one,
and saccharide comes from the Greek word for sugar.
The Greek word for sugar is -
I will do it wrong - sakcharon.
When people say something is sugar,
it is very, very sweet.
The Greek word for sugar is sakcharon.
Therefore, saccharide means sugar, monosaccharide - a single sugar.
This means sugar.
The general term saccharide means
not just simple sugar such as monosaccharides,
can also mean two of these things that come together.
There are other simple sugars, fructose and others.
It can mean several of those connected together.
We may have polysaccharides.
The whole class, saccharides,
is associated with carbohydrates.
We started with these two monosaccharides here.
And this is disaccharide.
This is disaccharide.
We have two related monosaccharides.
This disaccharide is just maltose.
The point of this video was to see
how can we start with these simple sugars,
these monosaccharides and form disaccharides.
In fact, you can continue.
You can continue the reactions of dehydration
or condensation and add
more and more monosaccharides, to build
longer and longer chains.
If you continue,
if you continue to extend the chains,
you will reach the world of polysaccharides.
Polysaccharides consist of very simple sugars,
many monosaccharides linked together.
This is also the case with sugar,
you will see that often in chemistry,
we have one building block, this single sugar here,
more generally, we can call it
monomer.
If we connect several monomers to each other,
a polymer will be produced.
Polysaccharides are also extremely important,
you probably ate some polysaccharides today.
I'm sure you have polysaccharides,
stored in their cells at the moment.
If we bind glucose molecules between them,
and continue the process,
we will get a polymer
often encountered in plants
such as starch.
Polysaccharide, which you can find in plants
is the staple, which consists of related glucose molecules.
For cells to have instant access to stored energy,
several molecules of glucose form glycogen.
Polysaccharides
consist of simple sugars,
of several related monosaccharides.
They are often found in biology.
You probably tried them and stored them
in your body at the moment.